[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le 7-8 week-end on va parler
actualités mais aussi loisirs d'ailleurs
voici les titres de ce vendredi 15
janvier l'actualité ce sont les
nouvelles annonces du gouvernement ce
qui concerne la crise sanitaire c'était
attendu mais c'est désormais officiel le
couvre-feu à 18h s'élargit sur tout le
territoire à compter de ce samedi
nous accueillerons à ce sujet marie le
bec député de la 4e circonscription des
yvelines dans l'actualité également le
nouveau collège de mantes-la-jolie
ouvrira ses portes à la prochaine
rentrée
un projet d'envergure toujours en cours
de construction est financée
intégralement par le département des
yvelines
enfin des escales game outdoor un
nouveau jeu de société à poissy et la
braderie du golf national qui se tient
ce week end les idées sorties et loisirs
de cillia guettent son go et aussi le
résumé de l'actualité de la semaine
[Applaudissements]
comme je vous le disais en titre le
gouvernement a fait de nouvelles
annonces concernant la crise sanitaire
et c'est désormais officiel le
couvre-feu à 18 heures était tendue à
l'ensemble de la france métropolitaine
les yvelines sont donc concernés cela
prendra effet ce samedi 16 janvier
on fait le point avec vous justin
brasier bonsoir jean castex a affirmé
que le virus continué de circuler
activement on a toujours deux souches de
variants qui circulent en france celui
d'angleterre et celui d'afrique et donc
pour limiter leur propagation vous
l'avez dit le couvre-feu à 18h
généralisés à tout le territoire
la mesure entrera en vigueur samedi pour
au moins 15 jours
donc tous les lieux commerces ou
services recevant du public seront
fermés à 18 heures écoutez la réaction
de quelques saint quentinois
on va avoir une réunion avec les
personnes du siège pour savoir justement
si on va réduire les heures maître du
chômage partiel
changer nos horaires c'est à dire
peut-être commencer plus tôt moi je
serais d'avis ni couvre-feu niveau qu'on
filme en ce que j'estime qu'on est quand
même des adultes et qu'on fait attention
à moi je suis tout à fait favorable
parce que je pense que cette nature
efficace on s'est quittés et qu'en
est-il côté éducation justin est bien
face aux risques de décrochage
d'isolement ou encore de difficultés
psychologiques des écoles resteront
ouvertes mais la surveillance sera
renforcée
trois points à retenir le protocole
sanitaire renforcée dans les cantines
pas de brassage entre les classes le
midi la pratique sportive en intérieur
elle est suspendue et enfin le dépistage
va être massivement déployées dans les
écoles pour un objectif de 300 mille
tests par semaine pour les lycées
maintien du fonctionnement hybride
moitié en distance et les moitiés en
présentiel après le 20 janvier et pour
les étudiants dès la semaine du 25
janvier
les premières années pour revenir pour
les travaux dirigés en 2000 groupe on
sait que les premières années ils ont du
mal déjà que la fac est un système
totalement différente du lycée là c'est
normal qu'ils aient du mal vraiment
rester dans les cours et rester
déterminée motivés donc moi je le
comprends totalement et un point sur la
campagne de vaccination qui suit son
cours
oui pour l'heure trois cent dix-huit
mille personnes se sont fait vacciner en
france près de 61 milles en
ile-de-france lundi 18 janvier en plus
d'être ouverte aux personnes de plus de
75 ans la vaccination sera possible pour
les personnes à hauts risques
plusieurs possibilités pour prendre
rendez vous donc les plateformes en
ligne type d'octo libre sante.fr le site
et puis un numéro vert qui s'affiche en
bas de votre écran merci justin pour
toutes ces précisions et pour continuer
à parler de ce sujet notre invité
aujourd'hui marie le bec député de la 4e
circonscription des yvelines député la
république en marche on sort vous êtes
avec nous du coup pour parler de ce
couvre-feu couvre-feu à 18h pour toute
la france pour au moins deux semaines
c'est ce que le premier ministre a
annoncé hier soir jeudi soir d'autres
pistes étaient envisagées on en a
entendu parler
un confinement le week-end avec le
couvre-feu à 18h et pourquoi pas un
troisième confinement alors pourquoi pas
dès maintenant
alors on a des résultats qui
apparaissent par rapport à nos voisins
européens
un petit peu meilleures sur le plan de
la situation sanitaire
on a une circulation active du virus
mais encore on est encore dans le
contrôle de cette épidémie ce qui permet
de limiter les mesures qui sont prises
et de l'appliquer seulement un
couvre-feu à partir de 18 heures plus
tôt qu'à 1 re confinement général sur le
tracteur ce qu'on a observé ces dans les
départements qui étaient en couvre feu
jusqu'à présent à partir de 18 heures il
y a eu une diminution du nombre de cas
et c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle
on étend à l'ensemble du territoire
cette mesure mais ce troisième
confinement n'est pas exclue dans les
prochaines semaines si jamais la
situation sanitaire ne s'améliore pas le
premier ministre l'a dit hier en
conférence de presse effectivement si
jamais la situation venait à se dégrader
brutalement et on sait notamment que le
variant britannique est plus contagieux
il faudrait prendre des mesures
immédiates pour limiter en fait la
dégradation très importante de la
situation et à une à nouveau un
engorgement
nos hôpitaux ça vient vraiment en
parallèle de notre campagne vaccinale
est en capacité de contrôler l'évolution
de cette épidémie sur le territoire donc
le gouvernement a également non pas on a
entendu des commerçants juste avant je
me reprends est ce que vous pensez qu
économiquement un couvre-feu justement à
18 heures donc pour ces deux prochaines
semaines
c'est tenable pour les commerçants je
crois que pour les commerçants mais
aussi pour l'ensemble des français
c'est une mesure qui est toujours
difficile parce que c'est aussi ce que
vous faites après votre votre vie
professionnelle qui est impacté mais
néanmoins et pour les commerçants le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
l'a rappelé il y aura tous les
dispositifs qui sont mis en place
jusqu'à présent qui viendront à partir
enfin qui seront pris en compte pour les
commerçants qui sont impactés par cette
mesure de couvre feu à partir de 18h
donc il y à un renforcement pour les
secteurs qui sont fermées
administrativement des aides qui
accompagnent il ya aussi un décalage du
prêt de garantie de l'état d' un an ce
qui permettra aux commerçants de ne pas
rembourser dès cette année mais bien dès
l'année prochaine
bien sûr que c'est difficile en terme
d'organisation et on peut l'entendre
mais ce qu'il faut dire aux commerçants
c'est que le gouvernement est à leurs
côtés pour leur apporter la compensation
économique de ce que représente cette
perte de près de quatre heures souvent
sur leur activité
autre annonce jeudi soir un objectif
tester plus d'un million d'élèves
d'enseignants dans les collèges lycées
écoles
comment ça va se dérouler marie le bec
alors c'est comme ce qui a été fait
jusqu'à présent c'est à dire des
campagnes de dépistage dans les lycées
notamment dans l'est dans les lycées des
écoles les collèges bien sûr ou
notamment on a des cas qui sont avérées
pour pouvoir prendre toutes les mesures
rapidement et limiter la formation d'un
cluster on sait on à la supposition
plutôt que le variant britannique
circulent peut-être plus facilement
parmi les plus jeunes et que donc il
faut qu'on surveille davantage parce
qu'il ne faudrait pas que les enfants
contamine aussi leur famille en rentrant
pour autant je le sais c'est important
pour les risques politiques c'est
important pour les enseignants cela
représente pour les parents il faut que
l'on mette tout en oeuvre pour maintenir
des écoles ouvertes et c'est aussi le
sens de ces campagnes de dépistage
massif dans les écoles et c'est sur la
base du volontariat que ce sera fait
pourquoi ne pas le rendre obligatoire
c'est sur la base du volontariat je
crois que c'est important aussi
pour ces pour les plus jeunes il ya
certainement l'accord peut être des
parents mais je crois que là il faut les
inciter il faut leur montrer que c'est
important
plutôt que de les forcer à se faire
c'est comme ce qu'on fait pour le vaccin
il vaut mieux convaincre que chercher à
imposer justement le dépistage
autre sujet pour lequel vous êtes avec
nous aujourd'hui marie le bec c'est pour
parler du baromètre des résultats de
l'action publique qui a été mis en place
par le gouvernement
il permet d'accéder donc à l'évaluation
de la mise en oeuvre de 25 réformes
prioritaires depuis 2010 est dans chaque
département de france et vous avez suivi
ce projet aux côtés de la ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique
amélie de montchalin quel a été votre
rôle alors le rôle des parlementaires
c'est bien sûr de faire remonter sur le
terrain les avancées du gouvernement qui
fonctionne celle où il ya des points de
blocage est en fait cet outil de
baromètre de l'action publique il est
utile pour nous les responsables
politiques pour nos oppositions aussi
pour venir nous challenge est pour vous
les journalistes voir ce qui est fait
mais je crois aussi c'est un outil grand
public et vous savez parfois on donne
des chiffres globaux pour l'ensemble du
territoire national or ce qui est
intéressant c'est à voir dans votre
département
ce qui bouge et c'est le rôle que la
ministre a confié aux parlementaires
c'est aujourd'hui d'être finalement de
consulter ce baromètre de voir ce qui
fonctionne de voir ce qui fonctionne pas
dans les réformes ce qui est ou plus ou
moins bien mise en oeuvre et ensuite
d'interpeller la ministre pour qu elles
aussi viennent voir sur notre territoire
et voir les points de blocage et faire
bouger les lignes
est ce que c'est une mesure mise en
place suite aux critiques du mouvement
des gilet jaune sur la transparence du
gouvernement macron je crois que ça bien
de toute façon en complément c'est une
bonne nouvelle mais l'exercice de
transport c'est à la fois un exercice
qui est difficile parce qu'il faut
pouvoir apporter les bonnes données les
bons éléments chiffrés mais en même
temps je trouve que c'est aussi un
challenge intéressant pour le
gouvernement
et même la majorité de dire on a fait
des réformes certaines sont en cours de
déploiement
mais toutes ne sont pas encore
parfaitement abouti et nous faisons acte
de transparence en vous mettant à
disposition c'est avec ces données elles
sont souvent public mais ce qui est très
intéressant avec cet outil c'est
finalement elles sont réunies en un seul
et même sur un seul et même outil
et elles vous permettent de vous
comparer et de vous comparer avec
d'autres départements
parfois vous avez l'impression que dans
votre département il ya quelque chose
qui vous disent fonctionne très
fortement et vous finalement un rendez
compte que ça marche pas si mal
notamment au regard des autres et donc
je trouve que c'est un exercice de
transparence qui est qui a vraiment qui
doit être en tout cas fait est établi
pour les citoyens vous l'avez dit ce
baromètre il suit les engagements du
gouvernement depuis 2010 sept sur huit
thématiques comme la transition
écologique ou encore l'éducation sur la
sécurité par exemple dans le
renforcement de la sécurité du quotidien
un grand projet de ce gouvernement il
indiqué comptabilise le nombre d'heures
de patrouille sur la voie publique des
forces de l'ordre se soient polis ou
gendarmes et dans les yvelines 599
miller 82 précisément pour l'année
qu'est ce que cela apporte concrètement
de comptabiliser ces heures de
patrouille alors ça permet de savoir
notamment en matière de sécurité ce qui
a été fait par le gouvernement la façon
dont sont employés nos forces de l'ordre
les missions qu'elles vont occuper et
puis peut-être d'établir aussi un
comparatif par rapport à d'autres
départements est en capacité de voir
s'il y avait par exemple un sujet en
matière d'insécurité dans les yvelines
un département limitrophe s'y lie le
fait d'avoir des heures de patrouille
supplémentaire permet ou non
de lutter contre cette cette insécurité
mais vous l'avez dit ça concerne nuit
grandes thématiques est certes exercice
il est aussi réalisables sur le nombre
de contrats d'apprentissage que vous
avez dans votre département par exemple
les hui on est passés auprès de 6500 en
à un peu plus de 9000 en 2020 et donc on
voit la progression et le déploiement
des réformes et c'est ça finalement le
sens de tous ces chiffres c'est vraiment
de dire est ce que les actions qui sont
décidés par vos élus par le gouvernement
est-ce qu'elle vienne concrètement en
oeuvre dans votre quotidien
merci marie lebey l'accès à la député de
la 4e circonscription des yvelines
d'avoir été avec nous sur ce plateau
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
l'actualité c'est aussi le chantier du
nouveau collège de mantes-la-jolie qui
avance la fin de construction est prévue
pour juillet prochain et pour une
ouverture au mois de septembre 2021
reportage avec sam le sad c'est officiel
le nouveau collège de mantes-la-jolie
ouvrira ses portes à la prochaine
rentrée en septembre 2021
le chantier avait démarré fin 2019 un
projet d'envergure entièrement financé
par le département des yvelines 31
millions d'euros en tout situé en plein
coeur du val fourré ce collège ans
rassemblera deux autres les
établissements chenilles et sésame
l'enjeu c'est vraiment d'ouvrir ce
collège sur sur le quartier l'idée c'est
que ce collège ne soit pas juste un lieu
utilisé par les collégiens mais qu'ils
soient ouverts en dehors du temps
scolaire et notamment les espaces de
type amphithéâtre
avec le mur d'escaladé associés qui sont
des espaces remarquables et qui ont
vocation à profiter à l'ensemble du
quartier
au total 600 élèves feront leur
prochaine rentrée dans ce collège
en plus d'un établissement flambant neuf
le projet pédagogique sera lui aussi
inédit
il sera organisé autour de quatre
maisons référente
on a pensé qu'il était plus facile de
trayons plus petits groupes et c'est une
maison référente se seront un peu la
façon de faire quatre petits collèges de
150 beaucoup plus agréable au sein d'un
grand ensemble de six ans on a essayé de
récupérer un petit peu le meilleur de
tout ce qu'on peut trouver dans le monde
l'idée
principal c'est de faire en sorte que
l'enseignement soit agréable ce faire
nous on veux réinsuffler ce qu'on
appelle le désir d'apprendre ce nouveau
collège dont la construction se
terminera en juillet prochain n'a pas
encore de nom
quant aux deux autres établissements
chénier sera déconstruit et transformer
en parti en légumes riz d'insertion et
sézanne n'a pas encore de projet défini
et l'actualité de la semaine c'est
mélanie poké qui nous l'a résumé en 78
secondes
[Musique]
cette semaine après deux ans de travaux
la nouvelle halle du marché des
clayes-sous-bois a ouvert la quarantaine
de commerçants vous trouvez ses clients
toujours pas de réouverture en vue pour
les salles de spectacle mais la création
continue sur saint quentin en yvelines
la mission dans sa compagne la compagnie
mémé banjo pour une représentation au
visage et en mai à versailles grand parc
le début de l'année rime avec
originalité pour le ramassage des sapins
de noël
l'agglomération a choisi de le faire en
calèche elle les salles de sport sont
encore à l'arrêt certains professionnels
se sont rassemblés devant l'assemblée
nationale cette semaine depuis le mois
de décembre 8 médiateurs et des agents
de proximité sillonnent les différents
quartiers de la verrière pour échanger
avec les habitants
leur objectif insertion sociale et
tranquillité publique
elle était députée européenne de la
circonscription ile de france 2 99 à
marielle de sarnez est décédé mercredi
13 janvier elle souffrait d'une leucémie
le groupe au losange lance arnaud lution
l'usiné historique de flins sera
transformée en établissement spécialisé
dans l'économie circulaire avec des
services dédiés aux véhicules
électriques à l'énergie le technocentre
à guyancourt travaillera sur la
connectivité du véhicule avec d'autres
entreprises installées dans les yvelines
[Musique]
après une semaine bien chargée quoi de
mieux que de se détendre le week end
comme chaque vendredi c'est yaga tsongo
nous propose ses idées loisirs et
sorties
[Musique]
merci les honneurs cette semaine nous
allons parler de loisirs en extérieur
les essais de gamer outdoor loisirs
privilégiées en ces temps de crise
sanitaire dans le centre-ville de
montfort l'amaury vous pouvez jouer en
équipe en vous munissant d'un simple
smartphone
nous avons suivi des joueurs avec
patrick tactique semaine découvrir la
ville de montfort l'amaury autrement
voilà le but de lescott game en
extérieur développé par la maison du
tourisme et du patrimoine et
l'entreprise cruciaux cette enquête
policière en deux parties la tong sang 7
et le retour du pire au corps axes
peuvent se jouer de 2 à 6 joueurs le jeu
se fait en autonomie donc les gamers
démarre chez nous et puis ils peuvent se
promener ils ont des indices sur leur
smartphone et ils peuvent jouer donc
dans la ville tout seul à l'heure qu'il
qu'il souhaite et au moment qu'ils
souhaitent
ce jour là trois soeurs sont venues
jouer direction le cimetière pour la
première étape on a une liste d'énigmes
et on se répartit chacun les énigmes
donc chaque qui n'en prend une est comme
ça on gagne du temps et on fait on a six
énigmes à faire pour terminer l'étape
après quelques minutes c'est dias mines
vient de trouver une énigme
j'ai trouvé le résultat c'était une
image il faut que je trouve le métier
est là du coup j'ai gagné deux étoiles
j'ai gagné aussi un indice une image que
je pourrai réutiliser tout à l'heure une
fois l'étape terminée une autre énigme
apparaît et vous emmène dans un autre
lieu du centre ville vous devez résoudre
une enquête policière en moins de 80
minutes pour des enfants sont peut-être
un peu normal moi je vais attendre
quelque chose qui sont pas évidentes
surtout en vantant le dit
c'est fort ce jeu s'adresse aussi bien
aux touristes qui souhaiteraient
découvrir la ville comme montfortois ça
peut s'adresser à aux habitants de
montfort en leur faisant découvrir
d'autres une autre façon de voir leur
ville et surtout qui lève les yeux parce
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de choses
cachées que les gens ne voient pas pour
participer à ce jeu il suffit donc de
télécharger l'application quest ix au
sur votre smartphone de payer 5 euros
par joueur et de trouver la clé de
l'énigme mystère à poissy nouveaux jeux
de société et développé par une famille
pisciacaise ils ont déjà créé une
dizaine petite dizaine de jeux de
société et ne compte pas s'arrêter là
nous nous sommes rendus chez eux
regardez christophe vermont et sa
famille ont toujours eu le goût du jeu
en novembre dernier ils ont lancé la
société jacques am éditrice de jeux de
plateaux et de jeux de cartes
c'est vrai qu'elle continue on cherche
une idée pour gagner assure de ma fille
et puis aujourd'hui moribond pour
peut-être faire un jeu de plateau où
nous retrouvons récupérer à wiltz
voilà l'idée comme ça tu vas apprendre a
eu pas mal d'idées qui sont arrivés très
rapidement et puis on s'est viandé ben
pourquoi pas effectivement
carrément les produire et essayer de les
vendre leurs articles phares mystère à
poissy un jeu de plateau à partir de 6
ans qui a un objet qui a été volé il ya
une personne qui a volé l'objet il faut
retrouver le duo fait donc c'est
globalement une sorte de cluedo en fait
sauf que plutôt que vous connaissez tous
ça se passe dans un manoir et sert à
nous on l'a fait carrément à l'échelle
d'une ville la partie dure entre 30 et
45 minutes et se joue seul ou en équipe
de 2 à 6 joueurs
l'idée de base c'est quand même de de
réunir toute la famille s'est
globalement c'est des gens qui sont
assez simple il n'ya pas c'est pas les
jeux type warcraft ou ce genre de choses
dont il ya comme des beaucoup de règles
à apprendre beaucoup de choses on est
comme ça des jeux très simples d'accord
où tout le monde peut jouer que ce soit
les petits les
les parents les ados les grands parents
et ses mystères à poissy est vendu dans
une boutique de jeux de société à poissy
également sur le site internet jacques
amitié jeu.fr où environ une dizaine de
jeu est proposé comme l g un jeu de
stratégie
je me suis beaucoup amusé à créer des
règles et j'ai eu on a fait beaucoup de
à dire de plateaux différents ça c'est
parti dans tous les sens et au final on
ne trouve un plateau qui est moi je le
trouve magnifique avec des règles un peu
alors certes les règles sont un peu
compliquées plus que de nos autres jeux
des jeux diverses et variées pour tous
les goûts et tous les âges prochains
jeux de société à l'étude pour cette
famille décliner mystère a dans d'autres
villes yvelinoise
[Applaudissements]
la crise sanitaire n'épargne pas les
musées qui sont toujours fermés alors
pour ne pas rester inactif beaucoup
proposent une offre numérique
nous recevons notre invité du jour
thomas sagory bonjour bonjour vous êtes
responsable du développement numérique
au musée d'archéologie nationale à saint
germain en laye le musée est
actuellement fermée mais votre site
internet lui est bien actif tout à fait
est au delà du site internet c'est tous
les canaux de diffusion numérique qui
sont mobilisés des réseaux sociaux aux
applications de réalité virtuelle aux
applications accessibles depuis depuis
chez soi
j'ai vu comment on peut faire une visite
virtuelle aussi de l'exposition
temporaire da les armements c'est ça
alors elle est en cours de préparation
vous anticipez un tout petit peu on est
en plein dans l'acquisition justement
des photos panoramiques 360 qui
permettront dans quelques dans quelques
temps de de visiter l'exposition
virtuellement d'accord et et de quoi
parle l'exposition alors cette
exposition elle elle plonge dans les
débuts d'une archéologie scientifique à
la fin du 19e siècle et notamment grâce
à l'impulsion de napoléon iii
donc on y découvre les premières
fouilles l'utilisation de la
photographie appliquée à l'archéologie
sur le site d'alésia par exemple ainsi
que sur les fouilles de rome et c'est
finalement une mise en abyme par rapport
aux enjeux du numérique à l'heure
actuelle puisque on est très souvent
dans l'utilisation de ces outils
numériques pour répondre à des besoins
qui sont les mêmes étudiez conserver et
diffuser les savoirs sur ses sites
archéologiques et les collections qui
dès qui en proviennent et on peut aussi
découvrir l'histoire de votre musée 1 je
crois tout à fait c'est très lié à
l'histoire de ceux de ce musée qui en
plus d'être riche de collection qui vont
d'être du paléolithique jusqu'à là
jusqu'au premier moyen âge est installé
dans un château
donc l'histoire de ce musée au sein ce
château qui a vu passer tous les rois de
france depuis le xiième siècle est très
intéressante a expliqué est à mettre en
perspective par rapport à la discipline
archéologiques
j'ai vu qu'il y avait des collections en
ligne toutes les oeuvres que vous avez
dans le musée est-ce qu'on peut aussi
aller voir en ligne où il y en a qui ne
sont pas en ligne
alors depuis plusieurs années
effectivement on a engagé un travail de
numérisation 3d on a actuellement à peu
près 400 modèles 3d nos collections qui
sont en ligne bien sûr et qui sont
disponibles
c'était bien loin dé plusieurs millions
d'objets que nous conservons donc c'est
un travail de longue haleine et dans
lequel nous sommes pleinement engagés et
qui nous permet à la fois sur les
questions de recherche mais aussi sur
les questions de diffusion de
valorisation de faire rayonner ses
collections des faire connaître au-delà
des murs de ce musée d'autant plus
lorsqu'il est fermé
il y a également des conférences que
l'on peut visionner tout à fait alors ça
fait partie justement là des évolutions
liées à la crise sanitaire
nous avons développé des conférences que
nous proposons en ligne veut dire des
plateformes de téléchargement et de
visualisation de vidéos et donc on est
engagé effectivement dans
l'enregistrement et la diffusion de ces
contenus
c'est vraiment un axe un axe de
développement
il est très important pour continuer à
faire connaître ses collections et à et
à stimuler un réseau d'archéologues
puisqu'on est vraiment un musée au coeur
d'un réseau très vaste à l'échelle
nationale mais aussi à l'échelle
internationale vous avez créé aussi une
application mobile
arqués au maine pourquoi alors cette
application justement elle est au
service des visiteurs pour les
accompagner dans leur visite et à
l'heure actuelle permet d'avoir accès à
un certain nombre d'informations liées
aux collections du musée et on a proposé
on a plusieurs parcours qui sont
proposés on a également des parcours
propre aux équipes qui permet d'en
savoir plus sur le domaine et les
plantes du domaine national qui lui est
encore ouvert et est ce que d'autres
contenus seront disponibles aussi en
ligne alors il y a déjà énormément de
contenu en particulier le musée
d'archéologie nationale coordonne une
collection qui s'appelle la collection
des grands sites archéologiques qui vous
permet de visiter virtuellement la
grotte chauvet la grotte de lascaux d'en
apprendre davantage sur l'archéologie
sous marine
et donc ce site qui est visible sur
l'archéologie point culture.fr permet de
découvrir toutes les dimensions de ces
disciplines archéologiques au delà des
collections du musée et en complément
des collections du musée d'archéologie
nationale et dernière question en quoi
c'est important de faire vivre le musée
malgré tout sur votre site internet
alors c'est vraiment le prolongement
d'une activité qu'on a qu'on a initié
avant cette crise sanitaire
toutes les questions que les visiteurs
peuvent se poser lorsqu'ils viennent au
musée ou ou lorsque lorsqu ils
s'intéressent aux collections ont
vocation à être diffusé donc là nous
utilisons les réseaux sociaux le site
internet pour faire connaître les
métiers il ya de très nombreux métiers
assez méconnu au sein de ce musée en
plus de son histoire et des collections
donc les outils numériques sont vraiment
une très belle caisse de résonance pour
faire connaître donner envie susciter la
curiosité et puis essayer de porter un
regard un regard nouveau sur ce monde
qui nous entoure qui évolue très vite
mais qu'il est aussi intéressant de
regarder avec un petit peu de recul par
rapport aux temps anciens et des
apprentissages qui peuvent nous nous
apporter merci beaucoup thomas sabo
risque d'avoir été notre invité merci à
vous
et pour finir cette page loisirs je vous
propose une idée de sortie pour ce week
end en prenant la direction du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
la structure organise une grande
braderie pendant trois jours au niveau
de l'accueil
l'opération débute ce vendredi et se
termine ce dimanche
l'occasion pour les golfeurs ou curieux
de trouver des promotions sur des
milliers de produits
on écoute catherine gaillard chargée
d'accueil au golf national
elle était au micro de michael almy dron
alors on retrouve du textile qui est
destiné aux golfeurs et on en golfeur
avec des réductions qui vont jusqu'à 60%
un large choix de chaussures des clubs
c'est les produits en général qui ont
bien marché de la saison d'avant et les
connaisseurs apprécient beaucoup ce
rendez-vous et s'y rendent avec fidélité
et le 7-8 week end se poursuit elle se
poursuit avec eléonore pour parler de
l'actualité
comme chaque semaine on retrouve un
journaliste de la rédaction de tv 78 qui
nous présente ce qui fera la une la
semaine prochaine cette semaine mélanie
poké journalistes de la rédaction est
responsable de l'émission 7,8 société
bonsoir bonsoir
alors la semaine prochaine on va
forcément parler comme chaque semaine
vaccination couvre-feu maintenant aussi
et on va parler d'un rendez vous
important pour les lycéens et les
étudiants puisque le 20 janvier vers le
mercredi les jeunes voulant entrer dans
l'enseignement supérieur devront
s'inscrire sur parcours sup
après trois semaines pour découvrir les
formations c'est le temps d'ajouter ses
voeux d'orientation dit voeux à formuler
par personne c'est aussi le moment des
journées portes ouvertes et des salons
mais avec lakovic 19 de nombreux
événements se font en vision de sur
rendez vous épidémie qui a aussi un
impact sur le choix d'orientation des
jeunes égoïsme en mai dernier un sondage
de l' agence de conseil et qu'un effet
est associé un futur bachelier sur
quatre connaissait que la crise avait eu
un impact changement sur parcours sucre
ou influence sur la hiérarchie des voeux
certains visages et de privilégier des
formations plus proche du domicile au
moins onéreuse ses possibles difficultés
d'orientation seront au coeur du
prochain c'est une société mercredi 20
janvier merci mélanie pour cette annonce
et c'est déjà la fin de votre 7,8 week
end on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
l'information revient lundi à 18h dans
le 7-8 journal présenté par grégory
canale et d'ici là je vous souhaite une
très bonne soirée et un très bon week
end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]